[Musica]
Posso sapere quanti di voi hanno un
telefono Android oggi
e quanti di voi sanno che Android oltre
a essere sistema operativo mobile più
diffuso al mondo e anche quello più
esposto ad attacchi
la ragione di questo è legata alla
scelta di Google di pubblicare sorgenti
di Android che da un lato incentiva gli
sviluppatori ricercatori a migliorare la
piattaforma dall'altro però invita anche
possibilità attaccanti a individuare
nuove vulnerabilità e a implementare
nuovi attacchi
Io ho un telefono Android e sono
consapevole però delle sue potenzialità
e dei suoi limiti perché l'ambito della
mia ricerca mi occupo proprio di Android
Security quest'oggi vorrei condividere
con voi alcuni attacchi che ho avuto
modo di studiare e vorrei farlo
attraverso un racconto
e attraverso una serie di gesti che
probabilmente molti di voi hanno
compiuto nel corso della propria vita
mi vendo a Padova sono venuta qui oggi
in treno e come spesso succede per
passare il tempo ho preso il mio
cellulare l'ho sbloccato e ho scorso le
schermate dei miei profili Social ho
visto una pubblicità che mi ha subito
incuriosito una pubblicità legata a
un'applicazione per la gestione di
eventi e uscendo spesso la sera per
spettacoli concerti sono andata a vedere
sul Google Play Store di che cosa si
trattasse questa applicazione prometteva
di acquistare e di rivendere i biglietti
così come di ricevere le notifiche
relative ai eventi futuri in base ai
miei gusti personali
ho visto il numero di download di utenti
che prima di me avevano già installato
l'applicazione e ho guardato anche le
recensioni e sembravano buone
installo subito l'applicazione e l'avvio
l'applicazione mi chiede due cose Primo
i dati della mia carta di credito
secondo i gusti personali per poter
inviarmi
notifiche relative ad eventi futuri
inserisco immediatamente i dati della
mia carta di credito perché penso che
così posso successivamente comprare
subito E più velocemente i biglietti dei
degli eventi a cui voglio partecipare
Continua a giocare un po' con l'app e
poi chiudo nel frattempo sono arrivata a
destinazione e mi avvio verso il Ten
Saloon
lungo il tragitto Siccome sono un po' in
anticipo decido di prendere un caffè in
un bar e di effettuare alcune ricerche
in rete prima di effettuarle però
controllo se per caso il bar ci sia un
wi-fi gratuito e sono fortunata perché
non soltanto c'è il wi-fi ma
quest'ultimo non richiede né
autenticazione né una password quindi
basta un click perché io si è collegata
al WiFi e possa navigare in rete senza
consumare i giga del mio telefono mi
collego e inizio le mie ricerche noto
con curiosità che però ci sono delle
pubblicità molto particolari molto
personali che richiamano le applicazioni
che ho installate sul mio telefono per
esempio vedo gli abbinamenti degli sport
che pratico e di cui ho le app
installate per tener traccia di tutte le
attività che faccio oppure vedo
pubblicità della mia App della banca che
ho di cui Ho installata sul cellulare
per gestire meglio il mio conto
incuriosita ma non troppo insospettita
finisco le mie ricerche bevo il caffè ed
esco dal bar lungo il tragitto a un
certo punto il cellulare squilla
vedo una notifica da parte della mia
banca la apro e vedo che è stata appena
effettuato un pagamento online di 500
euro Peccato che non sia stata io ad
effettuarlo
chiamo la mia banca per saperne di più e
mi viene detto che effettivamente è
stata fatta una transazione
blocco la mia carta e chiudo la chiamata
vado avanti e ricevo una nuova notifica
questa volta è una mail e in questa mail
si vede l'elenco completo di tutti i
siti che ho visitato mentre prendevo il
caffè e coda la mail C'è un testo che
dice abbiamo hackerato il tuo cellulare
siamo in grado di vedere tutte le
attività che effettui e se non vuoi che
questi dati sensibili vengano condivisi
con terze parti dovrai effettuare un
pagamento
cosa cosa posso fare a questo punto
posso solo buttare il cellulare
se anche voi vi state chiedendo cosa è
successo Quali sono stati i miei errori
e a Quali attacchi sono stata esposta ve
li spiegherò meglio cominciamo
innanzitutto dall'app che ho scaricato
dal Play Store questa app nonostante si
mostrasse come un'app per la gestione di
eventi in realtà non era altro che un
malware cioè un software malevolo che ha
bypassato i controlli del Google Play
Store per andare a rubare dati sensibili
In questo caso i dati della mia carta di
credito una volta che io inserite i dati
della mia carta questi sono stati
condivisi con un attaccante che ha poi
potuto effettuare il pagamento online
senza il mio consenso andando quindi
addestrare 500 euro dal mio conto in
banca la stessa applicazione poi ha
potuto sfruttare una vulnerabilità della
versione di Android che io ho sul mio
telefono e che non ho ancora provveduto
ad aggiornare ovvero consentire a
qualsiasi applicazione di recuperare la
lista di tutte le altre app installate
sul mio cellulare questa lista è stata
poi condivisa con terze parti ed è per
questo che mentre effettuavo le mie
ricerche in rete ho visto delle
pubblicità molto personalizzate
infine il WiFi a cui mi sono collegato
al bar Non era affatto il wi-fi del bar
ma era un WiFi generato e gestito
dall'attaccante che si deve proprio di
fianco a me e che col suo computer aveva
creato questo WiFi dal nome verosimile e
che mi aveva invogliato a collegarmi se
ancora non ho tirato la vostra
attenzione Provate a immedesimarvi nelle
vittime di questi attacchi provate
quindi a pensare cosa faresti se foste
voi i proprietari del conto che viene
svuotato a furia di transazioni
effettuate a vostra insaputa perché
magari avete condiviso con la persona
sbagliata i dati della vostra carta di
credito Pensate cosa fareste se magari
fosse il vostro datore di lavoro che vi
chiede di installare un'applicazione e
tramite di essa viene a scoprire Quali
sono le altre App che avete installate
sul vostro cellulare andando quindi
scoprire il vostro orientamento
religioso oppure il vostro orientamento
sessuale oppure pensate ancora cosa
potreste fare se la lista completa delle
vostre ricerche in rete fosse di dominio
pubblico
la sicurezza dei sistemi è complessa e
uno dei limiti È legato al fatto che
nonostante possiamo contare su sistemi
di difesa altamente complessi e potenti
la sicurezza complessiva di un
ecosistema Dipende sempre dall'anello
più debole e molto spesso L'anello più
debole siamo proprio noi gli esseri
umani
il messaggio che voglio trasmettervi
oggi non è di avere paura della
tecnologia che utilizzate ma di essere
più consapevoli dobbiamo smetterla di
pensare che gli attacchi siano un
problema di altri e che noi Non saremo
mai vittime ma dobbiamo invece
cominciare a prevenire gli attacchi e a
pensare a quali rischi quotidianamente
siamo esposti la tecnologia mobile ci ha
definitivamente migliorato la vita ogni
giorno compiamo tutta una serie di gesti
che grazie al nostro cellulare sono
diventati molto più semplici ma al tempo
stesso siamo esposti a un maggior numero
di rischi e dobbiamo essere accorti e
consapevoli di questi rischi
non è possibile sapere a priori tutte le
vulnerabilità che esistono e nemmeno
tutti gli attacchi a cui potremmo Essere
esposti Però possiamo fare possiamo
adottare una serie di gesti che possono
ridurre il numero di rischi e in
particolare ve ne vorrei elencare tre
che se io avessi fatto mi avrebbero
permesso di non essere Vittima degli
attacchi che vi ho elencato prima di
tutto avrei potuto controllare sul Play
Store chi fosse lo sviluppatore
dell'applicazione che ho installato
andando a verificare magari se fosse
un'azienda o uno sviluppatore noto il
secondo luogo avrei dovuto aggiornare la
versione del sistema operativo sul mio
telefono andando quindi a prevenire che
il malware stesso acquisisce la lista
delle App che io ho installate
non avrei dovuto condividere i miei dati
sensibili con questa applicazione
andando a inserire i dati della mia
carta di credito non sapendo non essendo
certa di chi fosse lo sviluppatore di
quest'app e infine non mi sei dovuta
collegare al wi-fi del bar senza prima
magari verificare che il wi-fi fosse
effettivamente gestito dal bar e non
magari da un attaccante con questo vi
auguro buona navigazione
[Applauso]